en
vous baladant dans les expositions les
musées les foires d'art les galeries
vous êtes vous déjà posé cette question
m règes détenir cette oeuvre
aimerait gela posséder la voir chez moi
et alors est ce que mon regard sur cette
oeuvre changerait
vous me direz c'est une question assez
surréaliste
mais n'est-ce pas à moi élevé par des
surréalistes de poser cette question et
même peut-être de tenter d'y répondre
des questions surréaliste j'en ai
toujours posé comme ici avec
jacques prévert et pablo picasso et
pourtant je n'ai que trois ans et demi
il faut dire que quand on est élevé par
des surréalistes et qu'on a comme grand
père un visionnaire comme et aimé maeght
et comme oncle en guise donc aussi bien
d andré malraux jacques prévert chagall
ou giacometti
et ils m'ont tant et tant d'autres ça
nous donne une force et une audace
évidemment incroyable
mais ces génies ne m'ont pas seulement
transmis un petit peu de leur savoir ils
m'ont appris surtout à aimer l'art et à
aimer l'histoire de l'art que l'ars
déroule en fait l'art ce qu'ils m'ont
dit est sans cesse en mouvement
il bifurque prend des chemins de
traverse peut prendre des autoroutes ou
ou des sentiers vraiment quasi inconnu
mais ils avancent toujours toujours
toujours
inexorablement il avance ce nourrisson
de toutes les innovations
mais que serait l'art sans partage mon
grand-père pour offrir pour partager ses
goûts ses découvertes artistiques
pour partager avec le plus grand nombre
a fait sa propre fondation au soleil de
saint paul de vence
aidé en cela par ses amis artistes
le premier d'entre eux georges braque
puis giacometti calder
chagall tant d'autres et bien sûr miro
miro qui en déployant son labyrinthe à
la fondation à doter
cet endroit déjà assez exceptionnel
à doter la fondation d'un jardin musée
miro est sans doute celui qui m'a le
plus appris il m'a montré la nature le
rapport de l'art et de la nature il
aiguisé ma curiosité me poussant même a
toujours posé des questions toujours et
encore davantage comme je suis en train
de le faire là sur cette photo c'est en
1966 et je crois que son regard
bienveillant et je peux dire attendri
sur moi en dit long et de notre
complicité
et du sens du partage c'est sans doute
grâce à lui que j'ai cet appétit de
découverte de découvertes artistiques
bien sûr mais aussi de toute forme de
modernité y compris technologiques et
les artistes et miraumont après une
chose vraiment fondamental il faut
regarder devant devant soi loin devant
et c'est en faisant cela qu'aujourd'hui
je peux affirmer que nous vivons les
prémices
d'une révolution dans le monde de l'art
et ce grand bouleversement ce
chambardement
vient des mft
alors qu'est ce que c'est les nft et
puis quand ce mot et ils rentraient
finalement dans notre langage courant
c'est très récent
mars 2021 quand beetle un artiste en
fait mike fink hellman
à une de ses oeuvres qui le fait
connaître mondialement
pourquoi parce que cette oeuvre
est vendu sur la blogo chaîne
l'équivalent de 69 millions de dollars
c'est un mais c'est un chaos sur la
planète
tous les médias on parle que ce soit de
la presse féminine ou de société ou
politique ou audiovisuelle tv radio tous
ont couvert l'information souvent ne
sachant pas exact lorsque sont les nfc
alors je crois que quelques explications
sont quand même l'effet faire
les nft known for giebel token sont des
actifs
détenus d'une façon unique sur la blogo
chaîne c'est un peu compliqué à
comprendre mais on va on va s'y faire ce
sont des éléments cryptographiques
virtuel et ils sont ils ont des codes
uniques cryptée bien sûr pour par
exemple le titre l'année la signature ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la blocs
chaîne permet de créer des sortes de
certificats actes de propriété acte
unique cryptée donc non falsifiable
et que ce certificat est attaché un bien
le bien peut être un bien immobilier un
nom de marque un nom de domaine les
objets d'art et bien sûr des oeuvres
d'art donc ce qu'on appelle un nft art
c'est en réalité un certificat
attaché à une image mais ça veut dire
que le certificat est détenu par une
seule personne
alors que l'image est accessible à tous
alors peut-être vous n'avez pas compris
mes explications un peu technique alors
je vais vous parler du premier nft ce
que moi je considère comme le premier
nft alors voyons voir ça sa date de
création
il ya débat sur la date de création mais
on peut la fixer à peu près à 15 cents
16 oui je dis bien
alors pourquoi est ce que moi je
considère que c'est le premier nft parce
que la comparaison finalement entre les
deux
prouve que c'est exactement le même
système
à chaque fois que je prononce le mot aft
on me rétorque
spéculation milliardaire oui mais
infiniment moins que ce qu'a fait
françois 1er avec un art de vinci
le jeune roi il a 22 ans veut prouver à
l'europe qu'il est le plus puissant le
plus riche et le plus au fait de toutes
les nouveautés y compris scientifiques
ou artistiques
c'est ainsi qu'il fait venir léonard de
vinci en 15/100 16 en france et leonard
deviendra le un artiste officiel
pour la cour du roi françois 1er
il l'a terminée mona lisa au clos lucé
c'est à dire en france
et le roi va acheter cette oeuvre et la
faire rentrer dans les collections
royales c'est d'ailleurs
aussi j'en profite pour vous expliquer
pour vous dire que c'est à ce moment là
que le marché de l'art a été créé
pourquoi parce qu'auparavant seuls
quelques reliques et antiquités étaient
vendus mais l'art contemporain ce qu'on
appelait l'art contemporain déjà
était en fait issues de commande et ne
quittait plus une oeuvre ne quittait
plus où son commanditaire ou le lieu
pour lequel elle avait été créée alors
que la mona lisa est achevée en france
et le roi l'achète à léonard
on peut dire que c'est un super
investissements vend des comptes depuis
toutes ces années ce qu'a rapporté mona
lisa la france est en plus en faisant ça
françois 1er a fait en sorte que sur les
15 20 tueur dont la paternité de léonard
n'est pas contestable et bien six
d'entre elles sont en france sacré
investissement qui rapporte encore
aujourd'hui alors on va faire un autre
comparatif avec justement les nft
l'image elle est immédiatement
identifiable
on la reconnaît tout de suite mais comme
les nfc ils sont trés il ya une identité
très forte
mona lisa tout le monde la reconnaît y
compris les gens qui ne sont pas venus
au louvre
quant à son créateur ça c'est mon clin
d'oeil c'était un artiste mais c'était
aussi un technicien un scientifique
absolument exceptionnelle
alors le plus important c'est le
propriétaire
finalement
qui est le propriétaire de mona lisa
alors certains vont dire le louvre mais
le lou n'a pas de collection
la france la france ça veut pas dire
grand chose ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses mais en tant que propriétaire ce
serait comme un finalement un fonds
d'investissement donc la france détient
mona lisa mais mona lisa est accessible
à tout le monde comme un effet une seule
personne le détient mais il est
accessible image est accessible à tout
le monde
elle pourrait même être vendu monna lisa
est peut être resté au louvre pour
autant on s'en fiche moi je m'en moque
de qui est détenteur de mona lisa
donc si on extrapole ça je considère que
les nft sont peut-être une porte
fabuleuse pour une totale
démocratisation de l'art et même un
accès gratuit à l'art le partage je
parlais tout à l'heure du partage c'est
vraiment ça on est en plein dedans alors
je vais liste est un petit peu c'est ces
avantages extraordinaires avec un
comparatif toujours avec notre cher mona
lisa
les neft et sont consultables par tous
via le web et des plateformes aussi bien
open 6 super rare qu'il y en a toute une
sorte
alors que le nouveau et payant
l'intemporalité
pour aller au louvre il faut respecter
et des jours d'ouvertures des horaires
tandis que le web est accessible
n'importe quand milieu de la nuit et
puis mondialisation
universalité même je te dirai car où que
l'on soit il suffit d'une connexion
internet pour avoir accès à tous les
ânes éviter que l'on veut donc il ya
vraiment presque un plus et le plus
encore qu apportent les nftc que
l'oeuvre elle a été créée sur un
ordinateur
et elle est visible sur un ordinateur
donc on n'a pas de déperdition alors que
mona lisa qui a vu mona lisa de près et
puis après tout elle est à travers une
vitre comme un écran d'ordinateur
alors c'est peut-être un peu autre
ancien ce que je fais mais réellement il
faut il faut se détacher de finalement
de notre système un peu conventionnel de
qui détient l'oeuvre qui ne la détient
pas l'important c'est d'y avoir accès
et puis alors voilà une chose
merveilleuse
on peut se créer son musée imaginaire
on collecte toutes les image que l'on
veut on n'a pas besoin de les détenir on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir ce fameux
document
pas document d'ailleurs ce fameux
certificat unique on constitue sa
collection comme malraux avec effet son
musée imaginaire
finalement il ne l'a monté qu'une seule
fois car tout le reste n'était que à
travers des photographies ou des
documents alors que là on se constitue
chacun son musée et puis alors il ya un
plus qui est très important c'est la
transparence du marché car toutes les
oeuvres qui sont sur la bonne chaîne
donc qui sont des élèves tu es
quand elles sont mises sur la blogo
chaîne on voit à quel prix elles sont
mises et toutes les transactions
successives ce qui fait qu'un artiste
contemporain automatiquement c'est un
artiste contemporain puisqu'il est sur
le blog chaîne va voir tout l'historique
de son marché
c'est finalement que l'offre et la
demande qui va créer le prix
alors est-ce que c'est pas réellement ça
l'avènement de l'art pour tous
il est moins cher aujourd'hui d'avoir un
smartphone que de venir à au louvre voir
mona lisa donc on a un accès totalement
gratuit ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui sur
la blogo chaîne alors qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de haine ft comme je disais
qu'ils peuvent représenter des biens
aussi bien
immobilier ou quoi que ce soit eh bien
là représentent déjà 20 % des mft de la
blog chaîne
alors vous ne lirez est ce que les
élèves tvh ont détrôné le monde de l'art
vont mettre au rancart l'arc on veut que
je pourrais qualifier de conventionnel
comme la peinture par exemple alors
l'histoire de l'art heureusement nous a
déjà montré
que plusieurs pistes plusieurs routes
plusieurs voies sont possibles
en même temps je prends l'année 1914
monet peint l'iman chef-d'oeuvre que
sont les nymphéas deux mètres de haut
sur 91 mètres de long
c'est un monument de l'histoire de l'art
il est incontournable 1914 pourtant la
même année un autre artiste français
décrète qu'un pan de bouteilles qu'il
vient d'acheter au bazar de l'hôtel de
ville est une oeuvre d'art est le porte
bouteilles de duchamp en
1914 devient un monument de l'histoire
de l'art il sera suivi d'ailleurs par
beaucoup de ce qui leur a appelé des
ready-made c'est à dire des des objets
qui était déjà fait et que il hisse au
rang d'oeuvres d'art
or aujourd'hui l'histoire de l'art
conserve les deux
aussi bien une image on va dire plutôt
classiques comme les nymphéas que le
porte bouteilles de marcel duchamp
donc gardons ces deux voies il y à
quelques artistes qui d'ailleurs très
tôt ont utilisé le digital pour
concevoir des oeuvres et pourtant ce
sont des peintres je prends comme
exemple un artiste japonais aki kuroda
qui vraiment est ancré dans la peinture
son atelier c'est vraiment presque
quelque chose d'assez conventionnel
et pourtant dès l'an 2000 il a conçu une
exposition
digital 100% virtuel rien de cette
exposition n'a jamais existé ni les
sphères ni l'endroit ni le les murs ni
le plafond les reflets dans l'essai sert
tout ça et digital tout ça a été créé
alors peut-être un jour on le mettra sur
la blogo chaîne il y a bien sûr outre
aki kuroda qui qui fait des créations
digital beaucoup d'artistes qui
maintenant sont passés sur la blogo
chaîne et qui créé spécifiquement des
oeuvres pour les néophytes et
les sujets sont très vastes et même
souvent certains sont issus de
l'illustration et
justement met au niveau d'oeuvres d'art
des créations tout à fait spécifique que
le
l'informatique permet beaucoup de choses
en pinceaux crayons quoi que ce soit ne
permettrait pas non seulement en image
fixe mais également en images animées
alors parmi ces artistes j'en ai cité
quelques-uns mais il y en a beaucoup ce
que je cite sont déjà rentrés on va dire
dans une sorte de panthéon déjà
d'artistes reconnus crypto punk alors
crypto punk c'est un studio vous voyez
c'est même pas un seul artiste c'est un
studio qui dès 2017 a créé presque dix
mille petits personnages mais un studio
au même titre qu'on pourrait dire le
studio de raphaël à l'époque où le
studio de léonard de vinci
et donc lui c'est vraiment le col le
l'artiste studio crypto punk est un des
phares de dnf tu es également akata aux
très importants android jones on voit
bien que healy à toute cette le côté
science fiction et
anticipation avec des oeuvres est
extrêmement détaillé parce qu'en plus
les avantages d'un ordinateur donc d'une
image digitale c'est qu'on va pouvoir
zoomer dézoomer zoomer ou dézoomer sera
sur un détail donc ça donne des images
absolument merveilleuse
je cite également markin du cil qui fait
beaucoup de vidéo également ce qu'on
appelle des gifs c'est à dire des
petites vidéos très courtes qui sont à
peine animée qui reviennent en boucle
mais aussi des vidéos plus longue et qui
n'existent on est bien d'accord que sur
le blog chaîne et bien sûr people qui a
fait parler de lui avec cette vente
record et qui a toute une partie qui est
très politique mais également beaucoup
d'anticipation autre chose comme ça
vous voyez les expressions et les styles
sont d'une richesse absolument infinie
je suis absolument persuadé que les deux
expressions conventionnel dessins
peintures installations sculptures
bien sûr photographie vous continuer à
exister moi j'ai un plaisir immense à en
avoir chez moi évidemment et pourtant je
me constitue une collection uniquement
de nft donc ayons des oeuvres chez nous
ayons des oeuvres sur un ordinateur vous
voyez c'est absolument passionnant et
moi je suis passionné par sa il faut
dire qu'il ya une règle j'ai une règle
dans ma vie ou du moins une phrase qui
me colle toujours
dans l'art comme dans la vie tout ce qui
ne me passionne pas m'ennuie